the reason the ketogenic diet works
remarkably well for losing weight and
weight maintenance a lot of people can
lose weight but not a lot of people can
follow an eating program that maintains
that weight loss and I think accusing
diet can do that remarkably well by
maybe some may argue is that it's it's
unpalatable so you're just less likely
to eat more right if you're excluding
carbohydrates but it has an appetite
suppressing effect so it's pretty clear
in the literature so so that's one
reason the acute is it most of the
people who are interested in the KJ diet
are interested in its weight loss
effects right so I think people need to
know that it's not a magic diet
I think dr. Atkins advocated that there
was a metabolic advantage that
suppressing the hormone insulin can
allow you to eat actually more calories
and you're burning more calories I don't
think the science support that it some
evidence there may be some evidence that
that's true but it's very negligible the
big effects of the ketogenic diet for
weight loss really come down to its
ability to to produce inadvertently
calorie restriction and allow people and
you're getting the benefits of ketones
to which after you adapt to the diet you
feel more lucid yeah more energy yeah
over time but you feel crappy the first
month typically that's the keto flu
right people can click it yeah I don't I
never really had that and I think maybe
athletes especially elite level not that
I'm definitely not low athlete but I did
go through periods where I would go
through calorie restriction and then
calorie surplus and stuff when I was
tinkering more with weightlifting stuff
but uh but I think that athletes enter
something called post exercise ketosis
so if they go out on a bike for four to
six hours they burn up all their
glycogen and they tap into their fat
they come back they're in a state of
ketosis
even though they're eating you know
three four hundred grams of
carbohydrates a day you know they can
enter that state so it you know this is
a so I think they are just by definition
more metabolic
flexible so when they follow the
ketogenic diet right many of them do
quite well and don't have a keto flu
keto flu is probably also due to
electrolyte imbalances or diuretic
effect my own diuretic effect or
hyponatremic effect you excrete excess
sodium things like that okay magnesium
maybe a little bit low too
mine was a little bit low and I probably
the only supplement that I take for the
Q Genk diet is a magnesium supplement
now I don't think I need it now because
I think I've adjusted my diet but it
just it's something that was a little
bit below normal at a point in time I
was probably not putting my diet
together well and that strike me as kind
of odd and explained some of the cramps
I was getting which is a potential side
effect that the gaging diet and I've
always used magnesium at nighttime so
can you walk me through what your day
looks like as far as what you eat and
like for breakfast lunch dinner and can
you also give me kind of a beginner's
grocery list for someone that wants to
get started and that someone who's
really interested in the keto diet yeah
well today I didn't eat anything so okay
nothing yesterday did if we use
yesterday as an example or maybe
tomorrow I'm trying to get my schedule
tomorrow but about two or three days a
week I do intermittent fasting and
that's a subject we didn't really talk
about but intermittent fasting is
something a lot of people are doing and
it's eating within a predetermined
window also called time restricted
eating so you could eat within an eight
hour window say from 12 noon to 8 p.m.
and then nothing after that time or
before that time that pushes your body
into a mild state of ketosis and if
you're on a ketogenic diet since you've
already adapted to using fat and ketones
for fuel it's easier to follow
intermittent fasting yep so today I am
doing intermittent fasting and my meal
will prop my first meal we'll probably
about 2 p.m. in the afternoon and in my
bag I have Wild Planet sardines
and I have
while planet sardines and maybe we'll go
out and like have a salad somewhere and
I'll probably put that like on the salad
on this LP like my first meal kind of
the day but yesterday it was we have
chicken sausage and we have eggs I think
I had like sausage and eggs for
breakfast but my food list I kind of
wrote down sort of what my wife does
shopping but like fatty cuts of meat
poultry and we get like the whole
chicken usually with a bone oh really
so my wife's Hungarian and she
introduced me which is pretty big in the
carnivore crowd is eating organ meats so
all the organs so mostly we hearts and
livers and that's a big staple in our
diet so a lot of heart a lot of liver a
lot
beef tallow like beef fat we'll use that
for different things will make stews I
get most of our beef actually through
butcher box which is an online service
and you just order it you subscribe to
it and this comes to yeah it's grass-fed
grass-finished yeah butcher box meats
the other company that has superior meat
is us wellness meats their products are
very good too and they also have like
organ meats that you can buy they have
like you can get ground heart make like
heart burgers its ground up with like
beef fat and things like that
so that and fish a lot of fatty fish
like sardines like I said will be my
next meal will get licious by the way I
tried that recently after hearing the
Tim Ferriss yeah what Wild Planet has so
they reached out and cut and sent me
sort of I didn't know that they have
like all these different fish varieties
so wild planet actually has all
different types of sardines that you can
go and they have all many different
types of tuna fish to in cans and
packets and they also have chicken and
they're super big on sustainability so
they've done their homework in regards
to sort of regenerative farming for fish
and sustainability so I feel good
supporting them purchasing their
products
butcher box us wellness meats are sort
of where we get a lot of our food from
we go to the local butcher - and get
like big bones for the dogs and okay
ground me and stumbling that
occasionally we feed our dogs what we
eat sour cream something I have every
night to fill basically to get in extra
calories so at the end of the day I'm
usually calorie deficient just because
I'm my days are pretty busy I make like
a chocolate mousse at night using
coconut cream sour cream and dark
chocolate baking cocoa but now I have
different powders that are like collagen
powder like chocolate collagen powder
that's like lightly sweetened with
stevia
I like throw scoop of that in with sour
cream and blueberries and something
really simple like every night it's like
a different recipe but notice what I had
last night and I'll stir that up and
it'll be probably like 70 grams of fat
just from the sour cream and then a
scoop or two of chocolate collagen with
wild blueberries so I get a couple
different companies sell wild
blueberries and I buy those that and
salad greens olive oil MCT oil you know
butter grass-fed butter what about the
coffee what's your what's your coffee
cocktail what do you put in your coffee
yeah so today well I'm drinking I'm not
advertising for them but a purity coffee
let coffee be thy medicine it's really
good coffee and I'm not trying to
advertise with it but uh but I have you
know I people send me different coffees
that I like to try so I typically I have
a French press and I make about almost a
liter of coffee in the morning not super
strong I'm not super weak just kind of
and I have one cup and then I pour the
rest in this and then I typically finish
this before noon and I tried to get no
caffeine definitely no caffeine after
like 2:00 p.m. but usually try to cap my
caffeine by 12:00 noon because I'm
really big in the sleep sleep hygiene
sleep I monitor these things part of
what we study I sold out your Instagram
a lot of times I don't put anything in
my coffee but there's a particular
product out that's really good it's
called momento it's really marketed
towards cognitive function and
Alzheimer's disease and it's got
everything from MCT to theanine two
versions of choline that can enhance a
seat of acetylcholine acetylcholine
urging function so I've been putting one
serving of that in there so it supplies
some MCTS which but it's not a whole lot
of calories so this that's the only sort
of calories that I had in my coffee
today so I've been because we've been
really busy and working on the farm and
everything a little bit less sleep than
normal and I noticed when I have that
the I do notice this particular
supplement is sort of giving me the
caffeine and the theanine team seems to
take the jitters off of the extra
caffeine didn't they don't get in the
morning okay
so that's what I've had today so the M
so the MCT and the butter yeah I don't
always use butter like I don't have
butter in this because it has a blend of
essential fats DHE DHA epa MCT again the
company is called momento right and it's
a new product that I'm trying I met them
at the metabolic Elle summit which is
and encourage your listeners to go to
the metabolic Elle summit if they're
interested in anything that I'm doing
it's like a top tier you know academic
clinical and also entertainment we had
JP Sears there oh wow yeah so he was our
entertainment for the gala it's an
amazing event but memento was they had a
booth there and it was the first time
I'd hurt I knew it was coming out and I
had two samples of it and I've been
using it and I love the product so only
about 20% of the things I actually try
do I like say something like this okay
so you try a lot of stuff I do I have a
lot of stuff that I still need to try a
lot of things I shall but yeah I love to
try products I do a lot of testing on
myself
[Laughter]